et effectivement je suis sur un article
franchement incendiaire et puis surtout
quand on lit l'article on a l'impression
qu'en gros je me suis fait passer à
tabac par un djihadiste quoi donc là
dessus j'ai réagi j'ai réagi en tant que
prof et en tant que citoyen
Christophe bonsoir alors à peine trois
semaines de cours est déjà 5 professeurs
agressés à Poitiers la semaine dernière
une enseignante giflée par la mère d'un
élève mardi à Amiens une autre aspergé
de gaz lacrymogène dans une salle de
classe vous aussi Christophe à Bordeaux
vous avez reçu des coups de tête et des
coups de poing heureusement Vincent
payant a annoncé la création d'une
délégation ministérielle chargée de la
prévention et de la lutte contre les
violences en milieu scolaire sans rire
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à
20h
[Musique]
Christophe rebonsoir vous êtes né à
Angoulême le 6 mars 1976 père cadre
commercial maire aide-soignante vous
grandissez à Bordeaux vous êtes
scolarisé dans les établissements
catholiques privés vous êtes choqué un
jour par un prof d'histoire
particulièrement militant enfin disons
actions françaises qui fait de la
propagande catho et anti-démocratique
alors qu'il est payé par la République
ouais je raconte ça parce que Sandrine
c'est important pour comprendre je pense
comment l'idée de laïcité
est devenue chez moi central voilà alors
votre adolescence c'est la fac
d'histoire elle rock'n'roll exactement
c'est sympa le rock'n roll je suis
toujours pas sorti
alors votre maîtrise en poche faites des
petits boulots intérim dans le bâtiment
quand il vacance travaux agricoles et en
2001 vous trouvez un poste de
surveillant dans un lycée professionnel
en Dordogne et là vous découvrez
l'envers du décor
vous dites absence totale de respect
pour l'adulte ouais pour l'autorité en
général ouais bon déjà il y a eu un
décalage de classe sociale clairement
moi je suis issu de la classe moyenne là
j'avais en face de moi des enfants de
prolos et des enfants d'immigrés
essentiellement en plus en zone très
rurale donc le décalage est total donc
effectivement ouais j'ai découvert dans
quel état d'esprit était les gamins
d'aujourd'hui quoi moi ce qui me fascine
chez les gamins d'aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il a jamais prise et que on a le
sentiment qu'effectivement il y a plus
du tout de limites en termes de de
d'autorité de de
une espèce de confusion générale sur les
valeurs quoi vous dites les jeunes
avaient le regard noir des fois ils ont
pas de regard du tout
des fois il vous ignore quoi et ça c'est
encore pire je crois ils font comme si
vous n'existiez pas ce qui est déjà une
première façon si vous voulez vous
signifier que bon ben voilà si
éventuellement vous aviez envie de faire
jouer votre autorité il va falloir
bataille alors un jour un élève en
fracasse un autre à coup de barre de fer
le mot me reste dans le coma une semaine
entre la vie et la mort mais cette
expérience finalement n'arrive pas à
vous dégoûter de l'enseignement
bizarrement non mais je pense que
j'aurais pas choisi ce métier là si
j'avais pas un minimum la vocation quand
même
alors en 2003 vous passez le concours
pour devenir professeur en 2004 alors la
première mutation le Val Fourré à
Mantes-la-Jolie finalement avec le recul
je me dis que ça a été la meilleure
école possible pour moi vous dites la
plupart du temps les gosses faisaient
comme si j'étais pas là et discutait
entre eux ils écoutaient leur MP3 ils
pianoter sur leur portable très vite
j'ai compris qu'en fait il y a parfois
une part de provocation qui consiste à
dire en gros on fait exprès de faire un
truc énorme pour voir comment vous allez
réagir et si vous réagissez on va vous
suivre enfin petit à petit vous prenez
de l'assurance et vous prenez conscience
aussi qu'avec 80% d'élèves musulmans
vous devez vous adapter par exemple au
moment du Ramadan on n'envoie pas des
mots me faire la gymnastique le vendredi
après-midi en période de ramadan et en
plus de ça ils étaient super gentils ils
faisaient chier personne avec ça
à la rentrée 2010 il y a dans votre
classe c'est un garçon qui s'appelle
Mehdi 17 ans 1m90 qui fait de la
musculation et qui a été exclu d'un
établissement pour comportement violent
mais dites-vous il avait pas envie de la
ramener il est plutôt l'air d'un gamin à
la recherche d'une deuxième chance puis
surtout ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé et
c'est là que j'ai compris que c'est un
mot intelligent c'est qu'il a aucune
fascination pour la violence mais dit on
l'appelle Mehdi évidemment son nom a été
changé vous soutient au cours de l'année
quand la discipline se dégrade
considérablement alors une relation de
confiance s'établit et un jour ou un
élève vous provoque Médine le vire de la
classe littéralement il a enfin c'est le
truc le plus hallucinant que j'ai jamais
vu en 8 ans de carrière je l'ai vu
bouillonner il était juste derrière il
s'est levé il fait vous me fait toucher
j'en ai marre il chope le gamin
par le callback et puis le fou dans le
couloir voilà mais le 11 septembre
dernier c'est l'accident vous faites un
cours sur le fait religion en France
depuis 1880 bref vous parlez de la
construction du principe de laïcité en
France
vous dites en général c'est au moment où
l'on aborde la loi de 1905 sur la
laïcité que les choses dérapent on leur
parle de laïcité de voile et à côté de
ça il voit que le calendrier scolaire
est calqué sur les fêtes chrétiennes
exact
il y a ça et puis il y a le sapin de
Noël aussi de mon point de vue le sapin
de Noël est associé à une célébration
religieuse alors vous avez un mot pour
décrire cette situation c'est à dire des
gens à qui en inculte le principe de
laïcité mais à qui on fait fêter les
fêtes chrétiennes vous appelez ça la
catholicité jusqu'à preuve du contraire
dans la Constitution c'est laïcité qui
est marquée mais dans les faits c'est
une catholicité qui se pratique alors là
Mehdi vous pose une question sur la
différence entre la France et le Maroc
et vous lui répondez la France est une
République le Maroc est une monarchie
une forme de dictature théocratique là
il se réduit son regard se noircit vous
avez peur ouais j'ai peur pour moi puis
j'ai peur pour les autres élèves aussi
d'autant plus que là je vois de suite
que il bluff pas quoi
physiquement c'est assez impressionnant
à avoir quoi alors là évidemment il vous
menace si vous insulte il veut tout
casser vous faites évacuer la salle de
classe vous vous retrouvez seul avec lui
il déverse sur vous un torrent
d'instabilité vous quittez la salle et
quand vous le recroisez il vous agresse
il manque de vous faire basculer
par-dessus la rambarde c'était
extrêmement dangereux c'est à ce
moment-là c'est à ce moment-là que
ma vie était vraiment en danger
concrètement bon c'est cool mon un petit
peu atteint mais bon il y a des gens qui
s'interposaient moi j'arrivais à le
contenir alors vous vous réfugiez à la
bibliothèque là la police arrive bon il
est maîtrisé à un moment vous pensez à
la démission vous rentrez chez vous
mettez sur un fauteuil vous dites
qu'est-ce que je fous là dedans et puis
vous vous reprenez vous dites il faut
que il faut que je continue ouais déjà
il y a un truc c'est que bon tout de
suite la couverture médiatique a pris
des proportions hallucinantes et et puis
donc du coup je vais regarder le mon
sud-ouest local puisque moi je suis du
Sud-Ouest et effectivement je suis sur
un article franchement incendiaire et
puis surtout quand on lit l'article on a
l'impression qu'en gros je me suis fait
passer à tabac par un djihadiste quoi
donc là dessus j'ai réagi j'ai réagi en
tant que prof et en tant que citoyen
alors vous gagnez combien par mois alors
ça dépend si je me contente de mon
traitement normal je suis à
1890 euros si je fais des heures sup je
peux dépasser les 2000 euros alors
est-ce que vous êtes assuré parce qu'il
y a 500 000 professeurs en France qui
sont assurés il y a une assurance qui
s'appelle l'autonome de solidarité à
laquelle je n'adhère pas alors Florian
Philippot le Front national vous ont
apporté
leur soutien ouais mais vous le refusez
c'est pas que je le refuse c'est que moi
j'appartiens à aucun parti j'appartiens
aucun syndicat après je suis pas certain
que le Front national soit le parti qui
est le plus fait pour apaiser les les n
raciales ou ethniques ou religieuses moi
j'ai des parents qui sont enseignants
dans le public donc je sais ce problème
ce que vous vivez alors peut-être que
vous refusez notre soutien en tant que
personne c'est votre droit le plus
absolu mais en tant que professeur
professeur de la République voilà on
vous soutient et c'est notre devoir en
tant que partie politique et ma nation
donc d'une partie du peuple ne vous
soutenir est-ce que ce que vous dites
aussi pose le problème du
multiculturalisme parce que ce que vous
appelez catho làïdïcité
que ça vous étonne honnêtement ça
devrait pas vous étonner il y a la
laïcité en France qui est mise à mal non
pas par le sapin de Noël aujourd'hui
voilà on sait très bien et vous l'avez
dit vous-même quelle remise en cause
quelle est mise à mal par des
extrémismes et souvent l'extrémisme
islamiste parfois un extrémisme juif
mais généralement ça n'est pas les Ultra
catholiques ce n'est pas le sapin de
Noël qui remettent en cause la laïcité
et je simplement pour éclairer cette
histoire de catholicité ce que vous
dites c'est que la France tout
simplement a des racines chrétiennes oui
mais voilà à partir du moment où vous
tolérez la présence d'un sapin de Noël
dans le hall du lycée je suis désolé
est-ce que c'est ça impossible le fait
de justifier le fait
légitimement d'interdire soit le voile
soit un autre truc qui m'énerve de plus
en plus c'est que le beaucoup d'élèves
passent leur temps à dire je jure sur le
Coran de la Mecque pour moi ça n'a pas
sa place dans une école de la République
on voudrait qu'on ne fête plus les fêtes
chrétiennes dans le cadre unique ou
scolaire toutes les fêtes moi
personnellement je pense plutôt pour la
laïcité parce que pour des raisons
techniques si chacun demande son petit
bout de gras ça va devenir
c'est que la laïcité il y a pas en
débattre il faut l'appliquer c'est tout
d'accord Patrick
ça fait plaisir de vous entendre parler
comme ça vous voyez ça ça fait du beau
moqueur parce que je vous reconnaissais
pas depuis le début et je savais plus
pourquoi j'étais contre vous donc là
dites-moi ce qui vous a choqué parce que
vous vous réduisez les choses vous dites
c'est eux alors c'est pas le sapin de
Noël le danger il vient de le dire c'est
qu'il n'y ait que le sapin de Noël qui
est un danger donc ça c'est caricatural
attends
je vais vous dire autre chose qu'est-ce
qui vit on est là pour la morale et le
son de morale qui va donner les leçons
de morale ce sont les parents vous le
dites ce sont les parents qui sont
responsables de ces enfants on demande à
l'école d'être responsable et d'éduquer
les enfants mais il vous arrive dans cet
état-là qui a humilié les parents qui a
fait que ses enfants ont vu leur parent
bafoués réduit à se taire vous savez
tous les fils d'immigrés qui ont vu
leurs parents je t'en supplie ne fais
rien ne dis rien on va être embêté on va
être embêté donc merci d'avoir parlé
comme ça j'avais oublié quoi je ne vous
suffit pas merci vous avez fait votre
petit chose
formidable vous avez un côté moderne
c'est vrai que vous avez vous amenez un
truc et je trouve ça et tout d'un coup
un certain temps je crois que vous ne
connaissez vous supporte pas pourquoi je
ne vous supporte pas ça ne me regarde
que que moi vous voyez mais il y a pas
de chaud vous remerci au lieu de traiter
le problème de Monsieur le problème de
la violence dans l'école quand même de
l'école dans l'école de la République
vous tapez sur le front national
bien facile bien facile comme le
showbize aime bien les frères Noël
pas le responsable vous démontrez que
vous ne connaissez pas la réalité et
vous le refusez ce détail
désolé faut rendre l'antenne et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu